well be in the modern world is for
blockchain um so we have kind of a major
initiative in the blockchain area it
kind of started with a whole study that
I did I've been doing for a number of
years about computational law and
computational contracts the just to talk
about it's actually a an issue that is
strangely related to proofs we talked
about the world of blockchain and what's
significant about it blog trains as
Ledger's for things are sort of
interesting but much more interesting is
the general notion well so blog trains
introduced like aetherium introduced
things like smart contracts running on
the blockchain but what's much more
interesting than smart contracts running
on the blockchain is computational
contracts running anywhere and a
computational contract is just something
where instead of writing a contract in
legalese you write it in code and our
Wolfram language is the best thing I
think the best language that exists has
a kind of computational communication
language to express the kinds of things
that one needs in a general contract and
so one might have a contract that says
you know it might be a snow plowing
contract and it might say if it snows
and it's a weekday and the webcam that's
that's according to a machine learning
classifier the webcam says the parking
lots been plowed then pay somebody a
hundred dollars and that whole thing
will be written as a piece of code and
automatically executed so we've got
quite a big initiative in this idea of
computational contracts and actually we
are creating a separate term business
Caldwell from blockchain labs that's
dealing with this the first big thing
for from blockchain labs the main thing
is creating computational fact source so
this is a thing which if you if you're
into the blockchain world these easily
called Oracle's that's a super confusing
word it means for them it means the
wrong thing it's been sort of co-opted
by different things but the basic
question is if you have a computational
contract and you want to know
did its did it rain today in such and
such a place then ultimately you have to
go to some source of facts some
computational source of facts to
determine that and with Wolfe NAFA and
our knowledge base we have the world's
broadest source of computational facts
in fact we have pretty much the only a
tall broad source of computational facts
and so people who've been experimenting
with kind of smart Oracle's and
computational contacts and so on a
hundred percent of them are using the
water now for API as their source of
computable facts so what we're trying to
do is to make that a more robust and a
more general kind of thing that can deal
not only with truly public facts but
also with things like facts from IOT
devices the the main issue is is the
validation of facts so when you have an
IOT device it's like there's a thing
that says you know your company will
give you a you know a fitness bonus if
you walk more than five thousand steps a
day did you actually walk those five
thousand steps so did you hook up a
machine to you know move your pedometer
you either have to model the world to
figure that out or you have to do some
kind of machine learning and on early
detection anyway that's an example
there's a whole what will happen with
computable facts is and when there are a
whole sort of networks of computational
contracts is once a computable fact is
determined there's this whole domino
effect that will occur once the
computable fact says so-and-so won the
election in such-and-such a place
there's a whole giant domino effect that
starts up so we're trying to figure out
sort of what the infrastructure looks
like to make sure we actually get the
right answer and to secure the whole
thing okay so let's see let's talk about
blockchain itself so we have a lot of
functions now related to blockchain in
the language so let's say let's use
aetherium as the blockchain of of choice
here and let's go look and let's go ask
what is the most recent block that was
mined on the etherium blockchain so
there it is not very big actually um we
could go and head and look at the
blockchain transaction data for a
particular transaction on now we're
looking at the etherion block chains and
that's going to hopefully retrieve that
block on the
that transaction from the etherion
blockchain and we could go ahead and say
um we could we could do all sorts of
things here we could say okay this is
going to ask for a dataset on the
etherium test net of a particular
address and the transactions the 20
transactions that were done on that
particular with that particular address
on the etherium testament um so now we
can go ahead if we want to be um we can
look at tokens that are running on for
example the etherium the public
aetherium network so this is looking at
the crypto Kitty tokens the crypto Kitty
token this is saying there's the token
address the total supply the number of
holders of crypto Kitty's is 82 thousand
which is interesting we could ask for
example for the transfers of crypto
kitties the most recent transfer so
these are the most recent crypto kitties
that have been received by people but we
could ask for um we could go to the
blockchain and we could ask for
so the crypto kitties are in IRC 721
token so we can look at all the things
on the etherion blockchain that
correspond the ERC 721 tokens and there
we see the the most used one is the
crypto kitty is followed by God's
unchanged and blockchain I don't know
what all these are um they're so and so
for example we could say let's look at
the account of the number of transfers
of all of those different kinds of
tokens of yossi sillman twenty-one
tokens we could do a log log plot of
that get the result all sorts of things
like this so this is a way of
interacting of treating the blockchain
bitcoin a theorem of the two that we've
done so far
there'll be a whole lot of other block
chains that we're working with treating
them as sort of a source of data a new
source of data in the world a bit like
financial data we also have our own
blockchain running in our cloud so you
can actually just put something into our
blockchain hopefully there's the the the
ID for that
and if we say we can retrieve that or
actually we can just look at the top at
the top of our blockchain and the last
block in our blockchain it's probably
just this transaction if it if it got
some and so now we can just say take
this thing which was stored in our
blockchain so we know so if you put some
you know if you put your lab notebook
results in our blockchain then it will
get hashed and it will build up the
blockchain will build up and if somebody
wants to say did you really put that
thing from your lab notebook in that
blockchain at this time one will be able
to say absolutely yes because every
subsequent thing on the blockchain is
hashed beyond that but then we can
retrieve from the blockchain and in this
particular case we'll get back a black
disc
okay so lots of things necessary to
support all of this blockchain Ori lots
of new things in cryptography like this
is elliptic curve cryptography now
supported we also have blockchain as a
complicated business and one of the
things that's really nice with all of
this functionality is we get to make
computational essays about how things
work on block chains and so this is a
computational essay about how the page a
public key hash Bitcoin transaction
actually works and you can actually run
it on the Bitcoin test net or if you're
more if you prepared to spend money you
can run it on the genuine Bitcoin
network and so people can learn how to
how this whole thing works as you can
it's quite complicated but everything
everything just actually works here